now the latest from the war in Ukraine
and oil refinery in southern Russia near
Ukraine was attacked and set on fire
overnight for the second time in two
days it's the latest in a series of
strikes this week on targets inside
Russia and the russian-controlled region
of Crimea Meanwhile we're learning about
new tensions and Russian forces on the
front line as Russian attacks continue
Charlie dagada is in eastern Ukraine
Charlie good morning
good morning to you Nate you know we've
been reporting all week how Russia has
intensified attacks here we'll get this
statistic from the U.S state department
since May 1st Russia has launched more
than 145 airstrikes across Ukraine
that's one missile drone or bomb every
hour 24 hours a day for four days
straight
a tense moment in the Skies over Kiev
last night a drone spotted overhead in a
capital bracing for Russian retaliation
a stinger missile shoots it out of the
sky
to the cheers of Glory to Ukraine
Ukrainian defense officials later said
it was one of their own which had gone
Rogue
but in a city that's been targeted by
Russian drones and missiles several
nights this week residents are
understandably jittery
especially after the attempted drone
strike at the Kremlin whoever was behind
it U.S officials tell CBS news they
believe the drones were locally
controlled but that doesn't rule out
Ukrainian involvement Maxine musica
designs and operates attack drones for
the Ukrainian Army it's a 100 local it's
obviously it's uh from inside of Russia
ahead of the counter-offensive cracks
are beginning to show in Russia's
defenses
the head of the Wagner mercenary group
posted this rant overnight standing over
several rows of dead Russian Fighters
here are the guys from Wagner who died
today he shouted their blood is still
warm he tears into Russia's defense
minister and the Russian general leading
the war in Ukraine Anthony
shouting these are Fathers and Sons
the Wagner group has waged much of the
heaviest fighting in this war losing
that support now would deal a critical
blow to Putin at the worst possible time
and we have just learned this morning
that the leader of the Wagner group says
his forces will be pulling out of Bak
moot by May 10th handing over to Russian
forces but considering his frustrations
at the moment that is going to be one
chaotic Handover
Gail
Charlie Daggett a reporting from Ukraine
thank you very much